Texas Department of Public Safety
Lieutenant Chris oliveiras joins me now
um
it was so amazing to me that they made
this move in the first place this was
the ideal candidate President Biden
picked him in part because he pushed
back against President Trump and his
policies do you fear it might become
even more
um more of an indifferent approach from
at least from Washington's point of view
well absolutely Charles good afternoon
great to be with you so we know for a
fact Charles is this is not going to
make any changes whatsoever you know to
what we're seeing On the Border unless
there's a significant change in
leadership at the top level uh we're not
going to see any changes whatsoever with
this border crisis unless the current
leadership enacts the policies that were
working prior to 2021 then we might see
it change but until then you see it
there on the footage you hear it from
The Correspondents that are out there in
the field you see the human smugly
events that are taking place this is
non-stop it's a it's on a consistent
basis it's not going to slow down and
unfortunately unless there's some unless
there's a significant change Charles
we're going to see this for the next two
years Chris do you think if that
so-called Red Wave if it actually had
materialized could there then have been
more pressure at least in Washington D.C
well I think it would have been
beneficial I think it definitely would
have helped it would have put some more
pressure on the current you know federal
government but again until we actually
see a significant change in leadership
at the top level uh we're not going to
see any policy changes with anything
related to The Border that's what that's
what it all comes down to if you heard
it from border patrol you in front of
the border patrol Union president
Brandon Judd who's even said himself
this could easily be fixed if they would
enact the policies that were working
part of 2021 but until then you know
unfortunately we're going to continue
seeing Mass migration we're going to
continue seeing fentanyl porn across the
border we're going to continue seeing
human smoking events taking place and of
course those illegal immigrants that are
coming across some of them losing their
lives at a record level and also the
non-gato ways and suspected terrorists
that are coming across our border that's
that's the reality of this current
situation and it's going to continue
happening unless there's a significant
change and somebody steps in and
actually puts those policies in place I
want to uh talk again about what's
happening there why this is so important
I was reading where
operation Lone Star by the the
Department of Public Safety there
has recovered 350 is is this number
right 350 million lethal fentanyl doses
is that number correct that's correct
that's correct Charles and one thing
that's unique about that amount of
fentanyl seeds that's that's fentanyl
that's not seized at the ports
eventually that's about seeds that's
already made it past the points I bet
you that's that's inside Vehicles that's
concealed and our state troopers are out
there working those main highways making
those corridors and actually season
these drugs so that's a that's a very
unique number a staggering number but it
just shows that if it wasn't for our men
and women of DPS out there uh stopping
these criminals stopping these drugs
that are coming across we would see a
lot more fentanyl coming across into our
country more human Smugglers more
Americans that are dying because of
those people drugs but this shows the
great work that they're doing every
single day and if it wasn't for
operation Lone Star
um those numbers would be even more
staggering than what we're seeing right
now and it's hard to believe that we
could but this could get much worse but
it could if it wasn't for men and women
that are out there right now yeah in the
meantime you know you talk about the the
cost the human toll on both sides of the
Border of course uh you know the
gotaways the drugs on the other side you
know enticing folks that make this Trek
particularly young women uh alone uh to
the coyotes to the mafias to the drug
lords it's it's mind-boggling that that
there's still not a serious sense of
urgency to to fix this we got less than
a minute to go so what happens on your
end from here
you know Charleston we thought that we
would see a change especially last year
with the Haitians and they're real and
then we actually thought there would be
a change when we saw you know 53
immigrants that lost their lives in San
Antonio and back of a trailer but
nothing was ever acknowledged by the
federal government so the state of Texas
is continue to step in and fill those
gaps and we have to because there's so
much activity that's taking place that
the American people are not aware of and
that's why it's important that we're
trying to Showcase as much as possible
and also with reporting that you guys
are doing also helps that the American
people know what's going on but we're
going to continue moving forward we're
working to sustain operations and if we
have to do this for the next two years
uh we will because someone has to do it
and obviously right now the federal
government's not doing what they're
supposed to do not secure the Border
well it's a tough job and we appreciate
you coming on thank you very much hi
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now